it's an experience to see Atomics I find
the experience entirely immersive you
know we've been fans of these characters
since we were kids there are things that
you won't experience in a regular
theater experience unless you do it and
that's exactly what I just said I just
let it better not really
I can tell you that Avengers infinity
war features all your favorite Marvel
superheroes from the last ten years so
me it was just like playing it's like
being in sports movie like the all-star
team I think that is just fun like if
you see the NBA all-star game
everybody's out there just having fun
that's that's what this feels like this
movie is about a war of infinite
proportion yes yes stones that must be
attained people coming together for one
thing we have what Thanos wants so
that's what we use I'm a great admirer
and enthusiasts of imax it's both a
visual and a kind of sonic audio
experience because it pulls you into the
action but also I think I'm the fun
right in saying the size of the frame
you actually get more of the shot for
every single frame it means you'll see
things that aren't supposed to be seen
like the bats I'm going train this
rather than proper boots you'll see that
the top of my house and be done so it'll
be just some greasy ball of mess no it's
wonderful it basically what it means is
you'll be wrapped around you'll be
surrounded literally by the experience
it's like an immersive tree
[Music]
[Music]
I want to see it seven more times you
see as well because that's a fan should
say
[Music]